unplug an entire generation of people
who use no cable news at all and if all
three of these collide you'd have oh my
god the perfect storm we've been talking
about this for a long time as though
there weren't enough proof that YouTube
is absolutely dead set on eliminating
voices of political dissent kuban's if
you see something you must say something
there's a D monetization that occurs
there's the flagging there's the
throttling there's there's the the new
guidelines which make no sense and by
the way thank you so much for people who
understand that who joined the Mudd Club
paying or 69 years a student at lot of
credit come /mo Club that ironically
allows us to provide more free content
on YouTube which gets in the bloodstream
and disrupts so paying for the premium
content allows more free content because
we got to fight back and YouTube I
understand some evidence here is
anecdotal right we talked about some
leftist channels that have been sort of
demonetized as well and some of it is
hearsay where you're saying okay maybe
there D monetizing you because you're
conservative maybe it's just guidelines
well we told you that our channel
specifically any video critical of The
Young Turks
what the monitor a little speech and
we've been talking about the youtubes
trending section for a while the
training section used to be trending
used to be what was popular what had the
most comments what are the most likes we
used to make those lists all the time
certainly as far as the highest
interactivity because people would
engage in in the comments section and
liked and disliked and often it would
spark a discussion
well that's long since been gone was the
YouTube trending list but here it gets
even worse the plot thickens
YouTube then said well you know what it
used to be algorithmic but some people
are gaming the system so now the
trending section is going to be kind of
curated by people who have a better feel
have their their finger on the pulse
know what it is that viewers want to see
which apparently includes personal video
announcements from The Young Turks
[ __ ] you for money this is this is
not a joke like it's not it's not
putting the training section a Young
Turks video that went viral because
something you know Alex Jones got into a
fight with him yeah it's putting in the
trending section chanc honest I
phone saying literally it's like it's
like him announcing his birthday party
and YouTube has decided this is clearly
the horse that they've bet on and you
can scan that entire face by the way you
won't find any conservative content you
find at the be Stephen Colbert Young
Turks there's a cozy relationship there
and here's something else it's not
working this at the time of this
recording I think it's been up for two
and a half days in a trending section a
hundred and thirty thousand plagues
that's really do you have any idea how
sad that it's bad when your next
transformer sixteen with ten million
views and that he even mark walberg
calling YouTube up saying hey you put a
next to my film trailer in the trailer
section okay it's embarrassing right
they're not even trying anymore now
they're not even trying to say well you
know what we actually thought that you
wanted to see this we actually thought
that you know clickbait sort of what if
would have stopped two Samantha bees
clearly deserving of being viral video
well I don't go watch this video but
it's quite literally I'm asking you to
give money to the Young Turks that's a
that's like a pledge Athan yeah usually
Armenian Genocide denying pledges on
it's seeping which which ties into our
next topic MSNBC they've been taking a
lot of flack this was the headline at
HuffPo with Trump in the White House
MSNBC resists the resistance and this is
for those who don't know this is based
on the story that Andy lack he's an
executive who's been brought over to
MSNBC and he's hiring some semi
conservative voices I mean there's Hugh
Hewitt Greta Van Susteren
I think megyn kelly is on there between
the MSNBC and NBC which is also an NBC
now now to be fair MSNBC is doing better
right now because anytime you have that
opposition voice right you see a bump
particularly after an election yeah so
that's what Fox News saw with Barack
Obama MSNBC will see that but it's
temporary those who work in media
Winterson it's temporary people are mad
and they're looking to sort of you know
they're the choir they they want that
red meat so you are seeing MSNBC doing
pretty well right now so again I would
bend the question why is Andy lack
hiring some conservatives like MSNBC is
a conservative network now but he's just
hiring some voices to balance out the
network
then HuffPo they trash him they say this
is their resisting the resistance
because now other Trump is president
MSNBC is the resistance really because
only a few months ago you were having
private dinners with Barack Obama and
doing his bidding and claiming that
anyone who questioned him was racist now
that Lee because it's trumpets or even
our veggie stalls I mean you're the
resistance what you're the resistance
you're a multi billion dollar media can
NBC Universal ABC Disney CNN Turner
Broadcasting Viacom everyone loves an
underdog story the resistance is not
against Donald Trump it's against you
they got the selection wrong by a wide
margin they're embarrassed and so now
the resistance is against the American
voter not just Donald Trump it's
important to keep that in context so why
would Andy lack be doing this if right
now MSNBC is doing well well this is
because he's forecasting what's going to
happen you can see what's going to
happen with cable news and this is why
YouTube is pivoting right now they're
trying to welcome cable into YouTube you
see them featuring a lot of the big
media companies content as opposed to
independently created content that's why
we appreciate those who join the Mudd
Club but they're also betting on The
Young Turks horse because they've had a
cozy relationship with them for a while
and the reason for this is a few things
there's an all-time high distrust in
media right now poll after poll shows
that people don't trust the media then
you have Generation Z as a generation
below Millennials the most conservative
generation of all time since a World War
Two the great generation a big part of
that is just because think about it
right you Millennials older Millennials
who are aged under raised under George
Bush again the sort of
anti-establishment voice the opposition
party uh George Brock against Bush no
effects raid against the Machine Rage
Against the Machine we want to fight
oppressive government with a Che Guevara
shirt you figure that one out
good liberalism isn't cool for them and
then you combine that with the biggest
factor on pluggers again generation Z
people who are just unlikely to
subscribe to cable at all at this point
they get all of the content online it's
actually surprising if you look at a
study people saw when vine still existed
YouTube as like the alphabet Network and
vine was sort of like cable it had
changed completely and then they really
didn't have any awareness of cable yeah
so and ELAC is being raked over the
coals by the left and I have no idea if
he's a conservative I highly doubt he is
but he's being raked over the coals
simply for higher
pretty moderate conservative voices in
anticipation of these things which when
they collide you've got about three
years maybe five and for the media and
for the leftist media it could just be
the perfect perfect storm
oh my god see here we have an
anti-establishment sentiment coming from
the north and an all-time-high distrust
in media coming from as South East
fascinating combine that with what we're
seeing coming in here from the southwest
unplug an entire generation of people
who use no cable news at all and if all
three of these collide you'd have oh my
god the perfect storm make sure the crew
below decks prepare this one was going
to get wild and wooly what the hell is a
difference just make sure you're
covering my ass and that we're ready for
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button it's a circular button now
that says subscribe if not head on over
the Young Turks that's probably more
your speed although they're coming over
at shank we know you're here watching I
can smell you from here there's also a
recommended video box playing right up
there you can join the monk little otter
with credit.com slash mug club for daily
content so we're not dependent here on
YouTube shank go/no-go you don't need to
stay here this isn't good for it's bad
for your soul